>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
AS WE CONTINUE TONIGHT REPORTING
FROM WASHINGTON, D.C., THE
SWAMP, AS I HAVE BEEN SAYING,
HOUSE REPUBLICANS NOW UNIFIED
BEHIND AN AGENDA TO HOLD THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE
ON EVERYTHING FROM THE BORDER TO
THE ORIGINS OF COVID, THE FBI,
ARE THEY POLITICIZED?
IS THE DOJ WEAPONIZED?
AND WE CONTINUE NOW WITH THE NEW
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, KEVIN
MCCARTHY, ALONG WITH STEVE
SCALISE AND ELISE STEFANIK.
ARE YOU ALL HAPPY WITH YOUR
LEADERSHIP NOW?
[ APPLAUSE ]
IF NOT, I WAS THINKING WE COULD
ALWAYS HOLE ANOTHER VOTE OR TWO.
>> I THINK I HAVE HAD ENOUGH.
>> Sean: YOU'VE HAD ENOUGH.
WE'VE KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR A
LONG TIME, STEVE.
THIS IS TO ME A PIVOTAL MOMENT
FOR THE COUNTRY.
FOR EXAMPLE, I DO THREE HOURS OF
RADIO AND I HEAR FROM MY
AUDIENCE EVERY DAY.
THEY ARE GENUINELY FRIGHTENED
ABOUT THE ECONOMY, ABOUT ENERGY,
ABOUT OPEN BORDERS, ALL THE
THINGS THAT IS ON THAT PAPER
THAT KEVIN HAS.
HOW REALISTIC IS IT THAT WE CAN
GET ALL OF THIS DONE?
>> SEAN, I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FINALLY SAID ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH.
LOOK, THERE IS A LOFT DESPAIR
OUT THERE.
FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING.
THE REAL PROBLEM IS THEY DID NOT
SEE WASHINGTON WORKING FOR THEM
BECAUSE WASHINGTON WAS WORKING
AGAINST THEM.
THE PROBLEMS FAMILIES ARE
FACING, FROM HIGHER COST, HIGH
ENERGY COST, OPEN BORDER, ALL
CREATED BY PRESIDENT BIDEN, THE
EXTREME AGENDA OF NANCY PELOSI
AND CHUCK SHUMER.
PEOPLE SAID, WE'VE GOT ONE
OPPORTUNITY TO AT LEAST PUT SOME
CHECKS AND BALANCES AND SEND
PEOPLE WILLING TO FIGHT FOR THE
FAMILIES LEFT BEHIND.
THAT WAS AT THE HEART OF THE
RULES PACKAGE.
BECAUSE BEFORE WE CAN START
FIGHTING FOR THOSE FAMILIES, WE
HAD TO CHANGE THE WAY WASHINGTON
WORKED.
THAT'S REALLY WHY THE DEMOCRATS
WERE SO CONCERNED ABOUT THESE
RULES CHANGES BECAUSE THEY
REALIZE THE PARTY'S OVER.
THE IDEA THAT YOU CAN WRITE
4,000, 5,000 PANEL BILLS BY THE
DARK OF NIGHT.
THOSE DAYS ARE OVER.
>> Sean: THAT 72 HOUR RULE IS
ROCK SOLID.
>> SINGLE SUBJECT BILL ALLOWING
MEMBERS, ALL MEMBERS NOT JUST IN
LEADERSHIP, BUT RANK AND FILE
MEMBERS TO BE ENGAGED IN THE
PROCESS OF GOING TO BAT FOR
THOSE FAMILIES WHO ARE
STRUGGLING.
>> Sean: ADD AMENDMENTS DURING
THE APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE NOW?
THIS IS PROBABLY MORE PEOPLE IN
THE PUBLIC THAT'S EVER BEEN IN
THE CAPITOL THE LAST TWO YEARS.
WE'VE NOW OPENED THE DOORS.
I WANT TO INVITE EVERYONE WHO IS
LISTENING.
IF YOU EVER DREAMED OF COMING TO
D.C., COME TO D.C.
YOU CAN SIT IN THE GALLERY AND
YOU CAN WATCH US DEBATE.
YOU CAN SEE YOUR GOVERNMENT AT
WORK.
BECAUSE THIS IS YOUR HOUSE.
THIS IS YOUR GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE JUST NOW EMPOWERED YOU
EVEN GREATER THAN EVER BEFORE.
THAT BRINGS ACCOUNTABILITY JUST
TO START OUT WITH.
WE WANT YOU TO JOIN WITH US.
NO MATTER WHAT PARTY YOU'RE IN.
BUT IF YOU BELIEVE IN SECURING
THE BORDER.
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO FILL UP
YOUR TANK OR HAVE MONEY LEFT
OVER FOR FOOD.
>> Sean: YOUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, THE NOTICE THEY SENT
OUT, EXPECT YOUR ENERGY BILLS TO
DOUBLE FROM WHERE IT WAS LAST
YEAR.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHY?
WHAT GAVIN NEWSOM HAS DONE TO
CALIFORNIA.
HE HAS SHRUNK OUR GRID.
THEN TELLS YOU YOU CAN ONLY BUY
ELECTRIC CARS AND CAN'T CHARGE
IT.
>> Sean: YOU CAN ONLY CHARGE IT
BETWEEN CERTAIN HOURS.
>> YOU'LL PAY 40% HIGHER.
THERE'S A REASON WHY, FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA, WE ARE DECREASING,
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING.
IT'S THE DEMOCRATIC POLICIES
THAT THEY HAVE TRIED TO PUT HERE
IN WASHINGTON.
FORTUNATELY, WHEN THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC SPOKE HERE TO CONGRESS,
YOU NOW HAVE A VOICE.
YOU HAVE A CHECK AND BALANCE.
WE WILL STAND UP.
THAT'S OUR COMMITMENT.
>> Sean: CONGRESSWOMAN, I HAVE
KNOWN YOU A LONG TIME.
ONE OF THE THINGS I LIKE TO SEE,
AND I'M SEEING, IS MORE
DIVERSITY IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
TO ME, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
THE PARTY OF COASTAL ELITES.
THEY'RE NOT REPRESENTING THE MEN
AND WOMEN THAT MAKE THIS COUNTRY
RUN AND WORK EVERY DAY, TO ME.
I SEE THE AMERICA FIRST AGENDA,
WHY I LIKE IT SO MUCH.
IT REALLY APPEALS TO ALL THE
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY THAT GET
UP EVERY DAY, WORK HARD, PLAY BY
THE RULES, PAY THEIR TAXES, OBEY
THE LAWS, RAISE THEIR KIDS AND
DON'T WANT THEIR VALUES
CONTRADICTED BY SOME TEACHER
WITH AN AGENDA.
ALL OF THAT IS NOW ON PAPER
WRITTEN DOWN.
HOW CONFIDENT ARE YOU THAT ALL
OF THIS WILL GET ACCOMPLISHED?
>> I'M SO CONFIDENT.
TAKE A LOOK AROUND AT THESE
WONDERFUL MEMBERS.
THIS IS THE MOST DIVERSE CLASS
OF REPUBLICANS EVER ELECTED IN
THE HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS.
WE HAVE MORE WOMEN THAN WERE
EVER ELECTED BEFORE, MORE
HISPANIC MEMBERS, MORE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEMBERS IN
MODERN HISTORY.
THIS SHOWS THAT OUR PARTY IS
GROWING.
I WILL TELL YOU, THE AMERICA
FIRST AGENDA IS A GROWING
AGENDA.
WE HAVE NEVER DONE BETTER THAN
WE DO TODAY AMONG HISPANIC
VOTERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WERE A HUGE PART OF
DOING THAT.
WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT IS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
JUDGE US BY THE RESULTS WE'VE
DELIVERED.
LOOK AT THIS PAST WEEK.
WE ARE ALREADY KEEPING YOUR
PROMISES.
ON DAY ONE WE REPEALED THE
87,000 IRS AGENTS.
WE JUST --
>> Sean: MOST HAD A TARGET ON MY
BACK.
BUT GO AHEAD.
>> THEY WERE TARGETING
HARDWORKING AMERICANS.
ABSOLUTELY.
HARDWORKING AMERICANS LIKE I
REPRESENT IN UPSTATE NEW YORK.
WE ARE MAKING GOOD ON OUR
AGENDA.
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THAT
COMMITMENT TO AMERICA TO SHOW
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT HOUSE
REPUBLICANS CAN ACCOMPLISH AND
THE RESULTS WE DELIVER.
>> Sean: WE HAVE A ROOM FULL OF
CONGRESSMEN AND WOMEN.
IS EVERYBODY ON THE SAME PAGE
WITH THE COMMITMENTS TO AMERICA?
EVERYBODY?
[ APPLAUSE ]
IS THERE ANYBODY -- IS THERE
ANYBODY -- YOU CAN BE HONEST.
ANYBODY THAT HAS DISAGREEMENTS
WITH IT?
NOBODY.
OKAY.
WHAT ABOUT THE INVESTIGATIONS?
ARE YOU ON BOA